PAUL SAXMAN: Hello, and welcome
to another episode of
"Google Maps Developer
Shortcuts." I'm Paul Saxman.
And today I'm going to talk
about getting data from Google
Drive onto Android and into
a Google Map on Android.
And that's using the Google
Drive web services, JSON
processing in Android, and the
Google Maps Android API v2.
So to show you what I'm talking
about here, if we go
over to the tablet I have
an application here.
It's just a very simple map.
And I actually have a bunch
of markers on here.
Each of these markers, if I
touch it, you can see it's a
city and a population.
So this is actually the natural
earth data that we
talked about in a previous
episode on getting
Drive data in a map.
If you haven't seen that
episode, definitely watch it.
Because that actually sets the
premise for actually serving
JSON data from Google Drive.
I actually added quite
a bit more data here.
So there's, I think, about 50
to 100 points on this map.
So not too exciting.
It's just a bunch of markers
with info windows.
This is pretty simple stuff
to do in Android.
But what I'm going to show you
now, if we go over to the
Chromebook, is-- gonna go
back over to my data.
You can see, like
I said before, I
added a lot more data.
About 100 points.
These are actually
all the cities.
We have the lat, longs,
population.
So if you saw the other episode,
this should all look
pretty familiar to you.
I tweaked the script a
little bit this time.
Instead of actually-- what I did
last time was taking the
values out of the spreadsheet.
And JSON is stringifying it.
So the JSON was an array
of an array.
So it was rows by columns.
What I did now, though, is
a little bit different.
Is I'm actually using object
literal notation to actually
create an object.
It's going to be a JavaScript
object, or, in this case, a
Google script object.
And then putting that into
a collection, an array.
And then stringifying
that array.
So the end result with that is
if I call this web service--
and setting up the web service
was in that previous show--
but if I call the service now,
you can see that I have array.
And then I have key
value pairs now.
Name, Tokyo.
Lat.
Long.
This is actually an
array itself of
the lat, long points.
And population, which is an
integer of very large size.
So seeing this actually
in Drive.
So this is actually in an index,
that HTML file, that
I'm actually serving from using
Google Drive hosting.
You can see all this data
plotted on here.
Same idea.
The very cool thing about this,
though, is that this
data is fully editable.
If I want to share this
information or share editing
rights to this script or this
spreadsheet, we can actually
modify this data live, and it'll
actually be represented
in our web app and in
our Android app.
So getting this into--
like I said before, this show's
more about getting it
in Android.
Show you how that's done.
We're going to go over
to GitHub here.
I set up a gist just to
capture this data.
Everything up above here.
So we have a lot
of information.
So I have all my
imports set up.
This is kind of standard
Android stuff.
If you actually use
the Hello--
what was it?
Hello, Map.
Actually, Chris Broadfoot did a
show a couple weeks ago that
was a five minute getting up
and running with Android
development with the Google
Maps Android API v2.
If you run that, you'll actually
pretty much start
with an activity that just has
the map and doesn't really
render much in it.
So definitely run through that
application if you want to
repeat what I showed here.
Run through that application
or that show.
Get that application set up.
And then just paste in what I'm
going to show you here.
So what I did is, in the
set up map operation.
So this is your own method that
you maintain yourself.
I'm actually running
a new thread.
And I'm calling this method
retrieve and add cities.
This is another method that
I've set up as well.
The reason I'm doing it in a
separate thread is because
it's a network operation.
I'm actually doing a web service
call, getting the
data, processing it, and then
plotting on the map.
If we got down to the retrieve
and add cities method, JSON
processing in Android,
truthfully, makes my eyes hurt
just little bit.
But it's not too bad.
All you really have to do is set
up your HTTP connections.
So I have a URL.
From the URL I'm getting the
HTTP-URL connection out.
And then getting a reader.
From there, I actually have to
get the data out in a string
so I can actually send it
to the JSON library.
So here I'm actually
just appending
it to a string builder.
And then later, what
I'm doing-- so I
have another method.
So this is actually
going the inverse.
Since I'm running in a worker
thread, now I have to actually
do the UI work back
on the UI thread.
The UI work is actually
plotting the
markers on the map.
Because that's a UI operation.
So from here, I have a method
that I called create
markers from JSON.
And then just string--
taking that string builder
and converting
it back to a string.
So this method is being called
on the UI thread.
And I'm just passing
it the JSON string.
And then last method, this is
where the JSON processing
comes into play.
Like I said, this isn't nearly
as clean as actually doing
JSON processing in JavaScript,
just because it's JavaScript
object notation and not JSON
or Java object notation.
But you can see here-- so I'm
just iterating over that array
that we showed earlier
on JSON objects.
And for each one of those, I'm
just calling map.admarker,
calling the marker options or
setting up the marker options,
applying the title snippet
and position.
And these three or four things
are actually just coming
directly out of the
JSON object.
So JSON object get string
from the name to string.
Then I'm getting the
population out.
The lat long.
That was an array of arrays.
And one more time.
If we go back to the Nexus
10 here, the end result
is pretty much this.
Could show you--
if I do tweak the data in the
My Awesome Data spreadsheet,
you'd actually see the data
manipulated here.
But you get the idea.
So thanks for joining
us this week.
Again, if you want to watch the
two prior episodes, it's
Kickstarting Maps Android
Development using the Hello,
Map Android application.
And Getting Drive Data
into Google Maps.
And then this will get that
data into Android.
So thanks for joining us.
And if you have any questions
or comments, let us know in
YouTube or on Google+.
And with that, thanks
for joining us.
And all the links are
in the description.
So enjoy.